[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
der Weg nach Kiew war rumpelig und es
brauchte drei Anläufe Bundespräsident
Frank-Walter Steinmeier ist heute in die
Ukraine gereist und hat endlich wolimir
selensky getroffen noch Mitte April
hatte der den Bundespräsidenten
ausgeladen er sei nicht willkommen
Hintergrund für den diplomatischen
Affront war die aus ukrainischer Sicht
verfehlte Russland Politik des
ehemaligen
spd-außenministers Steinmeier letzten
Donnerstag dann platzte Reise Nummer
zwei wegen Sicherheitsbedenken der
Bundespräsident ein Angsthase hönte die
Opposition jetzt also versuch Nummer 3
Annegret Oster über eine Reise mit
erheblicher Verspätung und später
Versöhnung
die Blicke vom Bundespräsidenten sie
sprechen für sich
Frank-Walter Steinmeier am Nachmittag in
Kiew bei einem Rundgang zeigt ihm
Bürgermeister Vitali Klitschko seine
geschundene Stadt
sehr wichtig der Bundespräsident besucht
unsere stadtstadt Kiew selbst steht hier
und sieht die Wirkung von diesem
Angriffe weil wir kämpfen und
verteidigen nicht nur unsere Städte und
unsere Landwirt Italien auch die Werte
genau das gleiche Werte hat was hat
Deutschland
wir stehen an eurer Seite ihr könnt euch
auf Deutschland verlassen das ist das
Versprechen des Bundespräsidenten der
sich am Abend tief beeindruckt zeigt
kann am Ende dieses Tages sagen ich bin
wirklich voller aufrichtiger Bewunderung
für den Mut
für die Unbeugsamkeit den
Freiheitswillen und die Tapferkeit der
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine eine
nachhaltige Verbundenheit soll nun auch
durch deutsch-ukrainische
Städtepartnerschaften befestigt werden
als eine Grundlage für geliebte
Solidarität
solche Partnerschaften über die ich hier
rede die helfen nicht nur im Krieg
sondern sie bauen auf Brücken in eine
neue gemeinsame Zukunft hoffentlich nach
dem Krieg
wie sich der Kriegsalltag jetzt anfühlt
erlebt Steinmeier bei seinem Besuch
heute Mittag in der Kleinstadt koyukiwka
nordöstlich von Kiew Luftalarm der
Bundespräsident muss in den Schutzkeller
hat uns besonders eindrücklich nahe
gebracht unter welchen Bedingungen die
Menschen hier leben Deutschland wird
weiterhelfen das ist die Botschaft des
Tages und die Friedenstaube Ausdruck des
wohl größten Wunsches der Ukrainer
die Ukraine hat keine Zeit der Winter
naht und Heizkraftwerke Krankenhäuser
und Schulen müssen repariert werden
davon konnte sich Steinmeier heute vor
Ort überzeugen wie viel das alles kosten
wird ist bislang schwer zu schätzen
zumal ja jeden Tag neue Zerstörungen
dazukommen und so ging es bei der
wiederaufbaukonferenz in Berlin heute
eher um das wie um das Wehrmacht was als
um die Frage wie viel Geld der
Wiederaufbau am Ende verschlingen wird
bevor wir mit dem zuständigen
ukrainischen Minister sprechen berichtet
Frank Buchwald über den Marshallplan 2.0
aus Berlin
er hat Bilder aus seiner Heimat
mitgebracht was der ukrainische
Ministerpräsident schmidhal dann aber
zeigt wirkt verstörend auch auf
erfahrene Politiker
Bilder die spüren lassen welches Leid
die russischen Drohnen in Kiew anrichten
und wie dringend die Ukraine Hilfe
braucht auch beim Wiederaufbau
internationale helferkonferenz in Berlin
es geht um viel Geld 350 Milliarden so
hoch schätzte der IWF zuletzt die
Kriegsschäden die Ukraine rechnet sogar
mit 750 Milliarden every Europe jeder
investierte Euro jeder Dollar jedes
Pfund und jeder Yen bedeutet Hilfe für
die Ukraine aber eben auch eine
Investition in die demokratischen Werte
überall auf der Welt
es geht um einen Marshallplan für die
Ukraine Hilfen für Kiew unterstützten
ein zukünftiges EU-Mitglied sagt
Präsident selensky und der beschreibt
zugeschaltet was sein Land für Europa
leisten kann
die Ukraine tritt für die europäische
Sicherheit ein nicht nur für die
Sicherheit unserer Nachbarn und die EU
kann mit unserer Hilfe auch die
russischen Energieträger ersetzen
Kanzler Scholz als g7-präsident
Gastgeber der Konferenz spricht von
einer Generationenaufgabe und sagt Kiew
langfristige Hilfen zu
mehr als jemals zuvor ist der
Wiederaufbau einer starken und
florierenden Ukraine jetzt unsere
gemeinsame Aufgabe ich bin überzeugt
vereint sind wir stärker wir stehen
zusammen und wir werden die Ukraine
unterstützen solange es nötig ist
ein Versprechen das Deutschland und
Europa lange Bänden könnte die
Hoffnungen sind groß auf allen Seiten
und aus Berlin ist uns jetzt der
ukrainische Minister für regionale
Entwicklung zugeschaltet olexie
chanishoff guten Abend
sie sind für den Wiederaufbau vor allem
in der Ostukraine zuständig also für die
Gebiete die die Ukraine nach russischer
Besatzung zurückerobert hat wie sinnvoll
ist dort eigentlich ein Wiederaufbau
dort wird doch immer noch gekämpft und
Russland wirft weiter Bomben
ja guten Abend vielen Dank ich möchte am
Anfang gleich einmal sagen dass es
wichtige Bereiche gibt wichtige Gebiete
die jetzt erfolgreich
wiedergewonnen worden sind in der
Ukraine nördliche Region nordöstlicher
Regionen darauf konzentrieren wir uns
gerade beim
Wiederaufbau und wir konzentrieren uns
darauf uns für den Winter vorzubereiten
das heißt Heizung und Energie für die
Menschen die Ostukraine ist ja nicht der
einzige Bereich wo das gebraucht wird
wir haben ja gesehen dass die Russen
seit Oktober schon Angriffe gemacht
haben seit dem 10 Oktober die am
intensiver Angriffe auf die
energiefrastruktur gemacht und viel mehr
Regionen wurden betroffen nicht nur im
Osten auch im in der Mitte im Westen und
im Süden wir haben also Blackouts also
Stromausfälle die wir einfach reparieren
müssen und deswegen sprechen wir auch
über grundsätzliche Unterstützung was
also die Ausrüstung angeht im Bereich
Energieversorgung das heißt es geht im
Moment weniger um Wiederaufbau als um
sofortige Hilfe für den Winter der jetzt
kommt was brauchen Sie da
for the winter
ist es ganz klar
wir sollten in der Lage sein heizen zu
können wir brauchen also genügend
Ausrüstung für die Energieversorgung
also auch mobile Komponenten Generatoren
heizstationen thermische Einrichtungen
und
wasserbehandlungsanlagen zur notwendig
sehr viel Infrastruktur ist vor kurzem
getroffen worden während der letzten
zwei Wochen und mehr als 300 Raketen und
Drohnen haben das Gebiet der Ukraine
angegriffen gerade auch Objekte für die
Energieversorgung und das ist jetzt die
Priorität das zu reparieren auf der
Konferenz heute in Berlin wurde ja ein
bisschen weiter nach vorne geguckt da
ging es um schwindelerregende Summen 350
Milliarden 750 Milliarden als Kredite
oder ohne Rückzahlung konnten ihnen ihre
deutschen Gesprächspartner eigentlich
erklären wo dieses Geld herkommen soll
dass die Bewertung der Bedürfnisse und
der Schäden jetzt erstmal sehr wichtig
ist gemeinsam mit der Weltbank und der
Europäischen Kommission haben wir uns
angeguckt was jetzt alles beschädigt ist
und wir sind dann auf 349 Milliarden
gekommen das ist der Betrag ab dem
ersten Juni heute ist der Betrag
natürlich für und Ende des Jahres wird
eine Neubewertung des Schadens geben und
die allgemeine allgemeine Wiederaufbau
der beginnt natürlich nach Kriegsende
aber nebenbei müssen wir kritische
Infrastruktur schon jetzt wieder
reparieren und im Moment sollte die
wieder neu entwickelt werden und
zurückgewonnen werden für die Gebete die
ich genannt habe im Norden und die
Bereiche die wir von der Besatzung jetzt
gerade befreit haben okay sie wissen
auch nicht wo das Geld herkommen soll
offenbar welche Garantien können Sie
denn auf ukrainischer Seite geben sie
haben sich vor Kriegsbeginn ja als
Minister selbst um die Bekämpfung der
Korruption gekümmert und eine Behörde
geschlossen die korruptionsanfällig war
wie groß ist das Problem der Korruption
in ihrem Land jetzt
signific and recovery wo required 2016
benötigt ein Wiederaufbau sehr viel Geld
einem bestimmten Stadium geht es darum
hunderte Milliarden Euro und
really dependent und ability kommt
natürlich immer darauf an dass die
Ukraine das Land reformieren kann so
dass strategische Reformen für die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit für Gerechtigkeit
und antikorruption durchgeführt werden
die haben das schon sehr viel Erfahrung
und Sie haben ja auch diese Struktur für
die Erteilung von
bau-lizenzen erwähnt die wir geschlossen
haben und der ukrainischen
Reform für das Land durchführen sie
haben natürlich Recht die nächsten
Schritte gehörten signif Fortschritte er
Form erfordern in den Reformen gerade
auch und die Reform die auf der
Tagesordnung sind
natürlich davon abhängen dass diese
reformel auch erfolgreich sind
vielen Dank für das Gespräch nach Berlin
ich danke Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir am Abend
aufgezeichnet weiter geht es hier jetzt
mit den Nachrichten von Gundula und dem
vorläufigen Ende der Chaostage in
Großbritannien der neue britische
Premierminister Regie sunak hat
schwierige Entscheidungen zu Bewältigung
der enormen Probleme des Landes
angekündigt Fehler müssten korrigiert
werden Priorität habe wirtschaftliche
Stabilität bereits am Abend stellt es
sunack erste Änderungen im Kabinett vor
überraschen wurde sweller braver man vom
rechten Parteiflügel wieder zur
Innenministerin ernannt sie steht für
einen extrem harten Kurs in der
Einwanderungspolitik zuvor war der
42-Jährige zunack von König Charles
offiziell mit der Regierungsbildung
beauftragt worden
Italiens neue Ministerpräsidentin Meloni
hat in ihrer ersten Regierungserklärung
eine nationalistische Politik
angekündigt die Parteivorsitzende der
rechtsradikalen fratellititalia sagte im
römischen Parlament dabei gehe es auch
um Änderungen an eu-vereinbarungen die
nicht funktioniert hätten wie die Reform
des stabilitäts- und wachstumspaktes
illegale Migration wolle ihre Regierung
stoppen in nordafrikanischen
flüchtlingszentren solle geprüft werden
wer ein Recht auf Asyl habe
das Bundesverfassungsgericht berät von
heute an über eine Klage der AFD sie
fordert staatliche Fördergelder für ihr
für ihre für die ihr nahestehende
Desiderius erasmusstiftung und
Gleichbehandlung denn andere parteina
Stiftungen erhalten Steuergelder von
zuletzt insgesamt etwa 660 Millionen
Euro im Jahr obwohl es dafür bislang
keine gesetzliche Grundlage gibt die
Richter werden sich mit der Frage der
Verfassungstreue von politischen
Stiftungen befassen die im Fall der AFD
nahen Stiftung von den anderen
Fraktionen bezweifelt wird mit einem
Urteil ist im kommenden Jahr zu rechnen
in den Nahen Osten israelische Soldaten
haben vergangene Nacht in nahtlos im
Westjordanland den Unterschlupf einer
militantengruppe gestürmt dabei wurden
fünf Palästinenser getötet darunter der
Anführer der zunehmenden einflussreichen
Miliz Höhle der Löwen der sich immer
mehr Jugendliche in nah bloß anschließen
aus Frust über andauernde
Auseinandersetzungen mit israelischen
Kräften bei Gefechten heute wurden
mindestens 20 Menschen verletzt
der gaspreisdeckel alle reden von ihm
aber niemand weiß so recht ob und wie er
funktioniert die Idee klingt einfach
wird das Gas zu teuer legt die Politik
einen geringeren Preis fest am besten
alle Länder der EU gemeinsam aber werden
die Lieferanten den Preis auch
akzeptieren ja sagen die Südeuropäer
weil sie ihr Gas loswerden wollen nein
sagen deutschland und andere
Nordeuropäer weil Gas gerade Mangelware
ist und die Anbieter jeden Preis
verlangen können und so diskutiert
Europa weiter letzte Woche auf dem
EU-Gipfel heute bei den energieministern
und der gaspreisdeckel bleibt weiter ein
Phantom Florian Neuhann berichtet aus
Luxemburg
es gibt diese schöne englische
Redewendung wenn ein Thema verschleppt
wird kick the CAN down the Roach die
Dose die Straße hinunterkicken und es
gibt den Vorwurf dass Deutschland genau
das gerade tut Energieminister Sitzung
in Luxemburg die 9 seit Kriegsbeginn
wieder mit dieser Frage was tun gegen
hohe Energiepreise ein gaspreisdeckel es
ist ein Vorschlag den die deutsche
Regierung für so ungeeignet hält dass
sie ihn seit Monaten aussitzt während
anderen die Geduld ausgeht ohne
besondere wir müssen einfach den Preis
senken den Verbraucher und Unternehmen
in Europa für Gas bezahlen es ist
dringend
Ilja
ist doch dass der Winter kommt und
sicher ist auch dass viele Staaten sich
Sorgen wie sich der Gaspreis auf den
Strompreis auswirkt
seit einem EU-Gipfel letzte Woche hat
dieser Deckel einen neuen Namen
dynamischer Preiskorridor und er hat
weiter einen entscheiden Nachteil jeder
versteht etwas anderes darunter die
einen wie Deutschland wollen einen
Korridor den nur mögliche absurde
spekulations-
das ist eine gute Frage
also
ich frage mich mittlerweile ob ich nicht
diskutieren muss über ein Mindestpreis
soweit muss es vielleicht nicht kommen
aber tatsächlich kennt der
internationale Gaspreis seit Wochen nur
eine Richtung nach unten seit seinem
höchst stand im August bis heute unter
100 Euro für die Megawattstunde Gas es
ist diese Kurve die auch der deutsche
Vizekanzler Robert Habeck in Luxemburg
wieder und wieder zitiert
[Musik]
heute sind die Gaspreise noch mal
deutlich gefallen heute morgen das liegt
daran dass wir politische Maßnahmen
getroffen haben in den letzten Wochen
und Monaten eine Botschaft wie gemalt
für einen Politiker wir haben den
Gaspreis im griff er singt mit einem
Haken der vielleicht wichtigere Faktor
für den Preis Sturz war sagen Experten
schlicht das Wetter
und jetzt ist es unerwartet mild in ganz
Europa geworden gleichzeitig sind die
Preise für Lieferungen Erdgas im
nächsten Jahr weiterhin sehr hoch also
hier ist der Preis weiterhin bei 140
Euro pro Megawattstunde als etwa 7 Mal
so hoch wie im Vorkrisenniveau die
aktuell niedrigen Preise bedeuten also
leider keine Entspannung unbedingt fürs
nächste Jahr immerhin das Europa künftig
mehr Gas gemeinsam einkaufen will da
sind sich die Minister heute einig für
alles weitere haben sie das nächste dann
also zehnte Treffen nach Kriegsbeginn
vereinbart in vier Wochen wer weiß wie
lange sich der gaspreisdeckel noch
verschleppen lässt
ist die Beteiligung Chinas an einem
Containerterminal im Hamburger Hafen nun
eine vernünftige wirtschaftliche
Entscheidung oder ein unverantwortliches
Risiko die deutsche Regierung streitet
darüber der SPD-Kanzler ist für eine
solche Beteiligung des chinesischen
Staatsunternehmens cosco 6 seiner
Minister und Ministerinnen dagegen Olaf
Scholz aber scheint wild entschlossen
das Geschäft abzunicken als
Kompromissvorschlag soll nun der Anteil
der Chinesen von 35 auf 24,9 Prozent
gesenkt werden was das bringt und ob der
Streit damit beigelegt ist weiß Ralf
Zimmermann von Siefert
er liegt genau wie sah wie zur
Innenstadt dieser toller Ort der
kleinste der vier Hamburger
Containerhäfen die Chinesen beliefern
die Hansestadt und das deutsche
Hinterland seit den 80ern mit Gütern aus
Fernost beteiligen aber durften sie sich
bislang nie an den Gesellschaften die
den Umschlag in Hamburg managen und
abwickeln man hat aber auch festgestellt
dass gerade in den beiden großen Krisen
die wir in den letzten Jahren gesehen
haben Finanzkrise 2009 corona-krise die
Räder dann ein Bogen um den Hamburger
Hafen machen weil sie eben nicht an den
Terminals beteiligt sind und vorwiegend
die Terminals auslasten wo sie selber
shares haben so das heißt der Hamburger
Hafen hat gerade in den Krisenjahren
mehr Ladung verloren als die
Wettbewerber die heftige Debatte um
einen Kompromiss hielt auch heute an
nachdem die ursprünglich geplante 35%ige
Beteiligung der chinesischen
staatsräderei cosco vom Berliner
Kanzleramt offensichtlich auf eine 24,9
prozentige Beteiligung gestutzt worden
war und dennoch Abhängigkeit von diesen
Staaten wie Russland und China ist uns
ja just in diesen Tagen knallhart vor
Augen geführt und deswegen sollte
Deutschland Erwachen sollte Europa
Erwachen das würde ich auch den Damen
und Herren in Hamburg sagen es geht eben
nicht nur um Hamburg es geht auch um die
Unabhängigkeit Deutschlands
Unabhängigkeit Europas in dieser Welt in
Berlin wo von den ampelkoalitionären
hinter den Kulissen um eine
Kompromisslösung gerungen wurde machte
auch die Opposition weiter beherzt Front
gegen jeden Einstieg der Chinesen mit
dem Verkauf der Gasspeicher an Russland
hat man erpressbarkeiten auf der einen
Seite in Deutschland geschaffen eine
Überlegenheitsgefühl auf der anderen
Seite das ist die Grundlage für neue
Krisen das gleiche darf uns jetzt in
China nicht wieder passieren in Hamburg
bemüht man sich schon seit Tagen darum
dass Politikum möglichst klein zu halten
und den Plan der chinesischen
Beteiligung aus dem Schatten der
gesamtstrategischen Debatte
herauszubekommen was geht nicht um den
Ausverkauf der Infrastruktur nicht um
Ausverkauf des Hamburger Hafens sondern
um eine Minderheitsbeteiligung an der
Betreibergesellschaft Container Terminal
Arbeitsplätze und das sichert auch die
Bindung der Lage Ladungen an den
Hamburger Hafen ob es nun zu dem
angepeilten Kompromiss und morgen zu
einem Kabinettsbeschluss im fernen
Berlin kommt das blieb bis heute Abend
auch in Hamburg eine offene Frage und
auch wie Deutschland eigentlich mit
derartigen strategischen Beteiligungen
Chinas künftig umgehen will
und wir bleiben bei Nachrichten aus der
Wirtschaft von Gundula der Arbeitskreis
Steuerschätzung hat mit seinen
Beratungen über die Entwicklung der
Steuereinnahmen begonnen offenbar können
Bund Länder und Gemeinden bis 2026 mit
höheren Einnahmen rechnen konkret mit
rund 110 Milliarden Euro mehr als
bislang geschätzt das berichtet das
Handelsblatt Treiber der Steuereinnahmen
ist die hohe Inflation wegen der
wiederum Deutschland im Kontext der
Energiekrise eine Rezession droht davor
warnt das Münchner Ifo-Institut mit
seinem aktuellen Geschäftsklimaindex
erneut Stefanie berrett die Stimmung in
den Unternehmen ist schlecht ja ist sie
allerdings nicht ganz so schlecht wie
befürchtet und was die Aussichten angeht
sieht man immerhin auch Licht am Ende
des Tunnels die aktuelle Situation
schätzen die 9000 befragten Unternehmen
als herausfordernd bis existenziell ein
kein Wunder steht doch eine
winterrezession vor der Tür so ein
breiter länger andauernder Rückgang der
Wirtschaftsleistung der vor allem
energieintensive Industrien wie die
glaschemie und Papierbranche treffen
dürfte weiterhin leiden zwei Drittel der
Firmen unterlieferengpässen Sorgenkind
bleibt der Einzelhandel hier fürchtet
man dass die Kundschaft wegen der hohen
Preise einfach zu Hause bleibt und dem
bislang boomenden Bausektor brechen die
Aufträge weg wegen steigender
Materialkosten und höherer Zinsen einzig
Dienstleister blicken optimistischer auf
die kommenden Monate Hoffnung schöpfen
viele Unternehmen aber aus dem 200
Milliarden Wumms und der in Aussicht
gestellten Deckelung der Energiepreise
volle Gasspeicher mindern zudem das
Risiko der gefürchteten gasmangelage die
milden oktobertemperaturen und die
Entspannung am Strom und Gasmarkt sorgen
hier im Aktienhandel für deutlich
bessere Stimmung der DAX gewinnt fast
ein Prozent und knackt die Marke von
13.000 Punkten auch heute war es wieder
die Wallstreet die den taktvorgab mal
schauen wie lange dieser Trend anhält
vielen Dank Stefanie nach Frankfurt
der Sportartikelhersteller adidas hat
die Zusammenarbeit mit Kanye West
beendet wegen mehrfacher verbaler
Ausfälle und zuletzt antisemitischer
Äußerungen des US-Rappers auf Instagram
und Twitter die von westentworfenen
Schuhe und Kleidung bringen adidas
schätzungen zufolge 1,5 Milliarden Euro
etwa 7% des Jahresumsatzes der von
Adidas verkündete sofortige Stopp von
Verkauf und Produktion der Betroffenen
Marke wird die Bilanz des fränkischen
Weltunternehmens wohl schwer belasten
das Jugendwort des Jahres ist Smash es
wird vor allem als Verb benutzt smashion
bedeutet so viel wie mit jemandem etwas
anfangen jemanden Abschleppen oder gar
mehr zugleich kann ein Smash auch ein
stell Dich einbezeichnen die Jury des
Langenscheid Verlages setzte das Wort
bodenlos auf Platz 2 und auf drei Macher
weltweit tummelten sich heute viele im
Freien es gab eine partielle
Sonnenfinsternis zu sehen Stück für
Stück schob sich der Mond vor die Sonne
für etwa zwei Stunden dann war das
Spektakel in Mitteleuropa schon wieder
vorbei aber auch in anderen Ländern zog
das Naturschauspiel Menschen in seinen
Bann
etwas Geduld braucht wer die partielle
Sophie heute verpasst hat die nächste
gibt es im Oktober 2025
vor dreieinhalb Jahren schockierte
dieses Bild die ganze Welt die
Kathedrale Notre Dame in Paris
Weltkulturerbe in Brand das Dach wurde
fast vollständig zerstört der Spitze
Turm stürzte ein 400 km nordostlich von
Paris in Köln verstanden die Menschen
vielleicht noch besser als anderswo was
eine solche Kathedrale bedeutet die
Bürger der Domstadt und darüber hinaus
in ganz NRW fingen sofort an Geld zu
sammeln die Dombauhütte bot konkrete
Hilfe an die Restaurierung eines ganz
besonderen Stücks von Notre Dame das
einzige übrigens das im Ausland
repariert wird Ralf Goldmann berichtet
aus Köln
als Notre Dame in Flammen steht da macht
Elodie Schneider gerade ein Praktikum in
der Werkstatt der Kölner Dombauhütte die
29-Jährige Französin ist
glasrestauratorin und hat ihren Job im
Elsass gelernt als klar wurde das vier
notre dam Fenster in Köln restauriert
werden sollen da blieb sie einfach hier
jetzt reinigt sie das Glas bessert
Bruchstücke aus und erneuert den Rahmen
aus Blei
werden kleinen Stücke Glas mit Sprünge
und so wir machen wieder mit Kleber mit
Silikon und vermisst und jetzt ist mal
wieder die verbleihung wieder um alles
zusammen und wie eine Person ein
bisschen so es ist der 15 April 2019 als
Notre Dame brennt und der Vierungsturm
einstürzt Hitze Rauch Ruß und
Löschwasser beschädigen einen großen
Teil der Kathedrale
der Kölner Dombaumeister Peter Füssenich
sitzt damals mit Tränen in den Augen vor
dem Fernseher
mit dem Brand von Notre Dame sind nicht
nur einfache Holzbalken verbrannt
sondern eben auch das können die
Erkenntnisse von Generationen des Wissen
um die Kathedralen originale Zeugnisse
aus zum Teil aus dem 13 jahrhundert die
Notre Dame Fenster sind von 1965 Werke
des französischen Künstlers Jacques le
chevalier so sahen sie vor dem Brand in
der Kirche aus jedes etwa 30
Quadratmeter groß
vier davon sind seit dem Frühjahr in
Köln jedes bestehend aus fast 80 solcher
Einzelteile in der Dombauhütte würden
sie zuerst gereinigt und aufwändig vom
Blei befreit die Fachleute haben zum
Schutz vor den Steuben eine spezielle
Kammer gebaut
danach musste jedes einzelne Element
fotografiert und katalogisiert werden
dann geht es an die praktische Arbeit
hier in der Werkstatt und die
Stabilisierung der bleihe die Klebung
von Gläsern die Stabilisierung von
Lötstellen also Brüchen die im Blei
gebrochen waren möglich macht das alles
eine Spendenaktion des Landes NRW und
der UNESCO bei der kamen mehr als eine
halbe Million Euro zusammen am 15 April
2024 soll und muss alles fertig sein
genau fünf Jahre nach dem Brand soll
Notre Dame wieder in altem Glanz
erstrahlen für die Dombauhütte und
straffer Zeitplan
wir müssen nachher noch Stück bei Stück
die ganze Fenster wieder Restaurierung
und nachher wieder einbauen in Notre
Dame de Paris Fenster dann will auch
Elodie Schneider dabei sein das Kölner
team will die Fenster persönlich nach
Paris bringen und dort auch beim Einbau
helfen bis dahin haben Sie hier noch
eine ganze Menge zu tun
und das war es von uns und wir empfehlen
Ihnen jetzt die Reportage aus der Reihe
37 Grad Thema ist der katastrophale
Lehrermangel an deutschen Schulen und
wie Quereinsteiger versuchen diese
Lücken zu stopfen
und um 0 Uhr meldet sich Christina von
ungarn-sternberg mit unserem heute
journal-updates uns gibt es morgen
wieder einen schönen Abend und tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter mit zunehmender
Erhitzung verschiebt sich der letzte
Sommertag immer weiter nach hinten so
gibt es in dieser Woche 25 Grad und
sogar etwas darüber ein Sommertag ist
eben mit 25 Grad definiert und diese
Wärme die hat sich schon mal über dem
Süden Europas angestaut um die 30 Grad
hier die wird angezapft diese Wärme von
diesem Tief auf dem Atlantik und kommt
dann von Spanien über Frankreich nach
Deutschland diese Wetterlage kennen Sie
vielleicht aus dem Sommer sie hat sich
mehrfach wiederholt bei Hitze lagen und
jetzt ist es ebenfalls der Fall wir
schauen in die Nacht da kommt im
Südwesten etwas Regen auf der verlagert
sich allmählich nach Nordosten hin im
Osten ist es trocken teilweise in
Gewässernähe bildet sich Nebel die
Temperaturen sinken dabei auf 13 Grad im
Südwesten Deutschlands und
Art in der norddeutschen Tiefebene
morgen am Vormittag ist der Regen noch
vorhanden vor allem in der Südhälfte das
ist aber nicht viel nach Norden hin da
scheint die Sonne zum Nachmittag dann
auch im Südwesten der Regen verschwindet
es gibt zwar teilweise noch kompakte
Wolken aber es bleibt trocken die
Temperaturen dazu schon mal bis 23 Grad
im Südwesten Deutschlands und 14 Grad
nach Südosten hin noch wärmer wird es in
den nächsten Tagen
Temperaturen bis 24 Grad am Donnerstag
und 26 Grad am Freitag und damit ein
schöner Abend